DEMMA ROSA RODRIGUEZ:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Demma Rodriguez.
I'm the Head of Equity
Engineering at Google.
And today, I'll be talking
to you a little bit
about a team I started called
Equity Engineering, the impact
and the opportunity of
designing for Google's most
vulnerable users first.
I'm really excited
to talk to you today.
And thank you so much
for being here with us.
Before we get started, let's
talk a little bit about what
Equity Engineering is.
Equity Engineering is a
comprehensive approach
to building equitable products
for underrepresented and future
users.
And what does that mean?
When I say "equity,"
oftentimes people
wonder if I'm talking
about the stock
market or financial products.
But really, equity is a
concept and has a definition
of providing the tools and
services and opportunities
to different users
that they need in order
to make sure that they have
outcomes that suit their needs
but also that meet
them where they are.
So working across
different communities,
what are the tools and
services and perspectives
that need to be understood
in order to make
sure that we are building
products and services that
help all of our users and
don't advantage some users
to the disadvantage of others?
But more about that in a minute.
Let's get through
the agenda and talk
about how we're going to
walk through this pretty
complex topic.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is talk about, what
are our pillars?
What are the guideposts
that we use in order
to frame this work?
Then we're going to
step into our goals.
Fundamentally, what
are we focused on?
How do we do it?
What is the model that we use
in order to get the work done?
And what is our approach
in continuing to advance
this work across Google?
Lastly, we'll talk
about the impact, what
are some areas of
opportunity, and some traction
that we've made.
What is our moonshot?
And by the way,
what is a moonshot?
What do Googlers mean
when they say that?
And then we'll talk
about some key takeaways
that you can incorporate
into your own practice,
into your teams, and
hopefully into your company.
So Equity Engineering--
some fast facts about us.
Equity engineering is a
multidomain, cross-product-area
effort that evaluates
processes, consumer products,
and internal systems.
We facilitate more equitable
experiences and outcomes
for users through process
experimentation in partnership
with the Chief Diversity Office
and all applicable product
areas.
We really have some
lofty guideposts.
The first one is we want
to transform development.
We want to infuse a mindset
of diversity, equity,
and inclusion throughout product
development and engineering
at Google.
And we have a specific theory
of change of where to start.
So we'll talk about that
in a little bit as well.
How do we know where to start?
How do we do this work?
We want to centralize research.
We really believe that ethical
user experience research
that is focused on constructing
user journeys and product
roadmaps that directly
impact underrepresented
or marginalized groups is where
we begin as priority zero.
We also want to make sure
that we're building capacity.
We want other teams
and other technologists
to understand how to approach
this work independently.
So we teach and
develop technologists
to understand and prioritize
use cases that negatively impact
underrepresented users.
We also understand that
underrepresented users
look and act differently
throughout the world.
As a multinational
organization, we
know that we have different
tools and different research
for different places
around the world.
We really work on
being multiethnic,
multinational,
cross-perspective in order
to include as many
users as possible.
So we really are beginning as a
horizontal team with scope that
focuses on HR
first-party tools, tools
that are built by
Google for Google,
and third-party
tools, tools that
are used across the
industry that we
have incorporated at Google.
Now, I'm sure you're wondering,
why start with HR first?
Well, at Google, our hiring
and professional development
processes are very
tailored to the way
that Google does business.
When I started
this team, I wanted
to focus on accelerating
Google's goals to build
a more diverse workplace first.
It's a core
philosophy that I hold
and that I wanted to
bring into the team
around cleaning up
your own home first.
Our theory of change is that
as we bring in more people
from all walks of
life, our products
will be better
and more inclusive
by default if
their creators come
from more places
around the world,
from different
socioeconomic classes,
religions, perspectives,
and walks of life.
Therefore we want to start
with the most pressing issue.
How do we make
Google a workplace
that reflects the
beautiful variability
and diversity of our
communities around the world?
This is a core
value and something
that differentiates our work
from other products inclusion
initiatives that seek to
educate the existing workplace.
While education is an
important tenet of our mission,
equitable hiring, progression,
and inclusive culture
are our first priority.
Secondly, we want to scale
our impact by joining forces.
We want everyone at the table.
We want to make sure that Google
program managers, engineers,
product managers, UX
researchers across the company
have an opportunity
to really focus
on how we can advance these
goals, internally first,
and then more broadly
throughout the industry
and throughout the world.
We also make sure that
each of our partners
are dedicated to the development
of products and systems
that work for our
users, especially
our most vulnerable users.
We want to drive parity
across those experiences.
And taking a quick step
back, driving parity
means we want to make sure
that our users who are enjoying
the most benefits, who feel
the most psychologically safe,
and who are able to really
advance their careers--
that there is not a delta
between their experiences
and other groups.
We want our groups that are
having a more difficult time
to have an easier go at building
the best careers that they can
at Google, at being
progressed, and being valued.
And so therefore our goal is
really to make sure that first
within Google and then
throughout the industry
and for all of our
users that everyone
has the same opportunity and
the same outcomes in how they're
able to enjoy a career at
Google, to enjoy our products,
and also to benefit
from the prosperity that
comes from technology
and the sector at large.
That was a lot.
And definitely, those
goals seem pretty good.
Sounds really good
on paper, right?
But how do we get this done?
Well, we get it done with
a theoretical framework,
a partnership model that
helps teams understand
how they can be successful.
What are their core
responsibilities?
But where are the
opportunities to collaborate?
So from the key performance
indicators side,
what the opportunity assessments
are with diversity, equity,
and inclusion, we think
it's really important
to defer to the teams that
have expertise in this area.
And so in that regard,
we partner really closely
with the Chief Diversity
Office to make sure
that we understand, what
is Google's broad diversity
strategy?
What is the prioritization?
And also, what are the
opportunity assessments
that we can carry forward?
We then help to
drive cultural change
by creating pilots,
training, and documentation
for our technologists in order
to help inform the product
strategy, the area
priorities, and team
objectives and key results.
And then lastly, we
empower all of the teams
across the Diversity Office
and also product teams
by providing consultations and
referrals, either internally
or externally to
experts in industry.
We help with prototypes
and experiments
so that we can innovate in
ways that help us to create
rapid opportunity assessments.
And we do reviews for existing
products that are in flight
and ready to be
produced or produced
and ready to launch
within Google.
So now let's talk a little bit
about the collaboration model
and how it's driven so much
impact here across our company.
To date-- and it's really
difficult to process.
But to date, just over
the last 18 months,
we have worked across
72 different teams
across Alphabet.
Oftentimes an
issue that we think
only impacts Google really
impacts multiple of our bets.
And so we've had the
pleasure of really working
across the entire
Alphabet community.
And we've done that by helping
to elevate sensitive use cases.
Oftentimes when we're thinking
about marginalized users,
we really want to make sure
that we take the burden off
of those communities
from having to describe
their own challenges with our
processes and our products.
And so we hope to elevate
those sensitive use cases
and help to protect users from
further psychological harm.
We also help to
inform process design.
So oftentimes in
engineering, it's
not just thinking about
what the tools do.
But it's also thinking about,
what are the processes?
How do we create a professional
development paradigm
where users from all
different kinds of backgrounds
can learn and grow
and understand
what their next steps are?
That then informs
our product design.
For a lot of Google's
processes, as we said,
it's really unique to the way
that Google does business.
And so therefore our products
can be quite unique as well.
Working product and
process together
helps drive mindful
innovation that focuses
on our underrepresented users.
We also then help with launches.
As we're getting ready to deploy
these tools and processes,
are we thinking about
all of the right things?
Do we have all our checks
and balances in place?
And then lastly, even once
something is launched,
there's a lot of change
management that comes along.
And so our program managers
help with change management
across the teams that
we're working with
to help lighten that load.
What we found as we
dug across our company
is that there were many
opportunities for us
to work with different
teams on improving products
and processes.
We have identified
over 159 improvements.
81% of those have
already launched.
And we know that we're
on track to make progress
in 2020, which is really
rewarding considering
all the challenges that
this year has brought.
We see ourselves moving this
work forward and helping
to improve the space
just a little bit,
even through some of
the hardest times.
We want to make sure that
our growth is sustainable
and that it can be-- and that
it is, in fact, sustained.
And so our resourcing
in 2020 and moving
forward is around distribution
across multiple disciplines.
Here at Google, we call
those disciplines "ladders."
And it essentially refers to
different domains of expertise.
And so right now, we're working
with user experience, program
management, product management,
and software engineering.
We believe that a
cross-functional and
cross-organizational
model is going
to help our work to scale.
And it's going to
help everyone invest
in this very important work.
We also know that
specificity matters.
And so we maintain a core
working group of 10 specialists
that really think
about equity cases
across multiple topics
that impact our company
and industry.
So back to this moonshot.
What does it mean
when Googlers say,
we are aiming towards a
moonshot, or our moonshot?
A moonshot is a Google term for
any big, long-term, expensive
project to solve an extremely
challenging problem that
has a chance of failing
but, if we succeed,
could fundamentally
change society.
And "expensive"
can mean anything.
It can mean time.
It can mean sweat equity.
It can mean financial
resources or prioritization.
But the term alludes
to, fundamentally,
this race between 1955 to 1972
to race to the moon as part
of the Apollo program.
Many said it wasn't possible.
There were many
failures along the way.
And the path towards progress
certainly wasn't linear.
But it was definitely
worthwhile.
And so our moonshot is just as
lofty and just as challenging.
We believe that
structural discrimination
is a form of institutional
discrimination.
And we know that that has a
real impact in engineering.
We understand that systemic bias
is an unintended outcome that
results from a lack of
representation of women, older
workers, Black and
Latinx people, nonbinary
and transgender people.
But we do believe that we can
dismantle the systemic bias
in engineering globally.
And that's really
the core moonshot.
We want to empower and drive
access to the tech industry
at large.
We understand that in the
rarefied air of companies
like Google, there
are many people who
never get an opportunity
to have their voices heard.
And we want to make our
company and our industry
more accessible to those people,
not just in the United States,
but all over the world.
We want to then share our
findings in the open source
community.
We want to promote universal
equitable frameworks.
Because this is really about
improvement and effecting
change, not just for ourselves,
but to companies like us,
to the industry, and to
users and people at large.
With that, what can we
do to effect change?
And since I'm sharing
this with you, what can
you do to effect change?
The first thing that I'm
going to ask you to do
is to take a hard
look in the mirror.
At Google, we have the brand
slogan "build for everyone."
But how can we actually
build for everyone
when we do not have a
representative workforce
or engagement model that
centralize the community's
feedback first?
The truth is we can't.
We have to really focus on
our most vulnerable users.
We have to be aware of the
ways that our products can
either advantage or
disadvantage groups.
And we have to start thinking
about our most vulnerable users
first.
With that, we know that we
can't build for everyone.
We are building on
behalf of everyone.
We want to build with everyone.
The work cannot
happen in a vacuum.
And it certainly does
not happen or will not
happen when the technology
sector as a whole
is still failing at
representation and hiring
and in retention.
That said, we're also not
going to pack up and go home.
So how do we build for everyone?
We build with our users.
We need to engage our
users across the spectrum
of humanity, engage our users
that are the least like us,
and be intentional
about centralizing them
first, not as an afterthought.
We also want to design
for the user that
has the most difficulty
accessing the product.
Building for those who
have additional challenges
are going to make our
product better for everyone.
Another way of
thinking about this
is never trade off accessibility
or any other equity
issue for short-term velocity.
Measure once, measure twice,
three times before you cut--
good, sound practice.
Measure equity
throughout your systems.
Do not assume it.
Recognize that your decision
makers are also subject to bias
and can be undereducated
in the causes of inequity.
So therefore you need a
mixed-method research.
You may not have the expertise
to identify or measure
the scope of an equity issue.
That's OK.
A lot of us weren't
trained to understand this.
And so while we're not
responsible for the lack
of knowledge, we are accountable
to gaining the information.
Remember that if you cater
to a single user base,
you may be
disenfranchising another.
These trade-offs can be hard to
spot and impossible to reverse.
So be proactive.
Partner with teams and
individuals that are subject
matter experts in diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
And don't be scared to
go outside of your team
or even outside of your company.
It's a big task.
It's a hard one.
It is most definitely a
moonshot, if not many.
But I want to leave
you with the thought
that change is possible.
The problems that we're
facing with technology today,
everything from surveillance
to disinformation
to online harassment, are
genuinely overwhelming.
And it's OK if you have
moments of feeling overwhelmed.
We're not going to solve
these problems overnight.
But we're also not going to
solve with the same failed
approaches of the past or just
the skills we already have.
So take a moment to
think about, what
are the tools,
services, and skills
that have gotten us here?
Meditate on that.
But then further think, what are
the tools, skills, and services
that we need to get to the next
iteration of what we would like
technology to be and
how we would like
humans to access these tools?
And who gets to be part of not
just the prosperity, but also
of the development of the tools
and services that help people
all over the world?
We know that we need to change.
And I want to leave
you with the thought
that it's possible
for us to change
if we all get in together.
Thank you so much for your time.
And thank you about learning
about Equity Engineering.